our friends over at uh Crane and Company
this great Sports show here at the daily
wire
um have are breaking some news this
morning and it starts with Riley Gaines
who is uh one of the female Collegiate
swimmers
who competed against Leah Thomas who is
the male swimmer pretending to be a
female and was allowed to compete
against women O'Reilly Gaines is one of
the few women who was directly impacted
by this and has had the courage to speak
out not the only one but one of the few
and they had an interview with Riley
Gaines I think we have a a brief clip of
that interview let's go ahead and play
that
if we let it there will be men
pretending to be women that ruin women's
sports but ranking first was the person
I had never heard of before and of
course this name was Leah Thomas Leah
Thomas did in fact formerly swim on the
men's team for three years I thought
surely the NCAA wouldn't let this person
compete with us the NCAA official looks
at me and says great job y'all tied um
The Trophy goes to Leah and he said well
for photo purposes Leah has to have it
wow Leah Thomas who used to be will
Thomas is now dating someone that used
to be a man that's now a woman and they
consider themselves lesbians very
interesting Dynamic the things they
practice actively are interesting they
cut off parts of their Mill Parts but
left other parts these testicles are in
a jar stop we were being sidelined to
validate the feelings and the identity
of a man
okay so there's uh some of what was
revealed and uh Jake crane is on his uh
Twitter account has laid out a thread
this morning with a lot of this
information
[Music]
um at J crane underscore if you want to
go see for yourself so I'll read a
little bit from this
and this is what it says
uh says this is a thread we never
expected to write we sat down with NCAA
Women's swimmer Riley Gaines and she
shared some info about Leo Thomas so we
did some digging and now we have a lot
of questions is this what the NCAA
thinks a woman is warning what we found
is jarring
and I don't know if that's an
intentional pun given some of the
information we find out later the
jarring part but there's some literal
jarring that has gone on apparently Leah
Thomas appears to have two Instagram
accounts his public account Leah K
Thomas featuring a small handful of
generic photos promoting messages like
let trans kids play then a private
account which is Leah basically Leah
timmis with an I rather than an o in our
research we found the observance
um uh someone Nicole walrus a name who
identified multiple IG posts about Auto
gynophilia that Leah Thomas under the
account Leah timmis allegedly engaged
with AGP aragonophilia is a males
propensity to be sexually aroused by the
thought of himself as a female
a similar image like by Leah timmis is
still found on Instagram account
um of uh of Gwen weiskopp which is
Leah's alleged romantic partner
Gwen who identifies Leah as his
girlfriend is also a quote unquote
transgender woman according to a
GoFundMe for Gwen's breast augmentation
he's also an unlicensed social worker
living in Philadelphia
um
and then more information about this
person
um
lots of some of the stuff I don't want
to read it's so disgusting
are Gwen and Leah in an exclusive couple
or in a polyamorous sex pod one user
called crybaby hell
writes nice polycule like by Gwen on a
photo of Leah Gwen and two other trans
people in the post Gwen tags a third
member via stuffed animal in bed with
Leah
so then apparently there's some sort of
poly Amorous thing going on
um and
later on we hear about
Gwen posted a mysterious round-shaped
organ item in a clear Ball jar
so does this mean that testicles were
removed and put in a jar I guess were
left to speculate about that there's
some Satanism stuff
um a lot of very disturbing images as
well that they dug up and all of this is
you know it's posted to the internet but
it was on a lot of the stuff was on
private accounts some of it was on
Public Accounts just nobody took the
time to go and find it now
so what's the point here
I think the point's rather obvious
um
it's not surprising to me anyway that
Leah Thomas is a depraved pervert
according to the information that they
found here
that doesn't surprise me
um
but what it reveals and and rather what
it what it confirms with any thinking
person should have already known really
is that this is all this is a fetish
okay this is a this is a a a fetish
Community if we could even call it a
community and that's what it is Auto
gynophilia okay is as it says they're in
the thread Auto gynophilia is the men
who are who are uh
thrilled by the thought of themselves as
a woman
okay they they they they get off on the
idea of themselves being a woman
which by the way
that is not the same thing as actually
thinking that you are one
that's the important point now even if
Leah Thomas actually believed that he is
a woman that wouldn't at all make him a
woman and so it wouldn't change much or
it shouldn't
but it becomes all the more grotesque
and absurd when you consider the fact
that even these people who claim to
identify as women many of them really
don't they don't even believe what
they're saying about themselves and yet
we're supposed to believe it this is a
fetish
he gets a thrill out of pretending to be
a woman and walking around like a woman
and going into the women's locker room
it's a thrill it's a fetish thing and so
what we're being told is we have to
participate in your fetish
Leah Thomas becomes sexually excited by
the idea of other people seeing him as a
woman and by competing against women in
uh you know in women's sports it's all
part of a fetish and what the women in
these sports are being told is that you
it's not even that you have to affirm
his self-perception
as Twisted as that would be on its own
it's actually that you must participate
in this man's fetish
okay he gets turned on by the uh by by
the idea of himself as a woman and and
even more so if you uh participate in
that charade and so you have to
participate
because he has a right to act out his
depraved fetish
um in public and with your participation
that's what the women are being told
and as I've been saying for so long this
is the case
it's impossible to know for sure of of
all the people these days who claim to
be trans or whatever it's we can't see
inside their minds so we don't know
exactly what's going on we can't say for
sure all we all we can talk about is
what is the physical reality and so we
know that they are not they claim to be
a certain thing and they're not that
thing we know that because we understand
physical reality
but there's a lot of very good evidence
some of it in this thread here
that even if we could see inside their
minds
um they are they are not they're
misrepresenting in public what their own
perception is
and for a lot of these men in particular
they don't even actually see themselves
as women they they know that they aren't
that's the whole point of the fetish is
to pretend to be something that they're
not
Auto gynophilia explains can't say what
the percentage is but it's a large
percentage of these trans quote-unquote
trans men
especially especially the The Men Who uh
quote unquote transition later in life
even if it's when they're 19 or 20 but
in particular the cases you know think
about someone like Rachel Levine
transitions as middle aged man
this is not someone who the whole time
really thought of himself as a woman and
perceived himself that way
this was a a sexual fetish that he
finally decided that he was going to
dedicate his entire life to and and also
require everyone else to participate in
that
that's what so much of this is
now for women
it's often a very different thing
especially adolescent uh girls who get
caught up in this for them it is you
know social contagion it's
um it is self-loathing it's fear about
their own bodies and the way that their
bodies are changing uh it's you know
it's a lot of that it's like um it's a a
fear and loathing of of who they are
that's being expressed in this way
foreign
so they're they're
many different kinds of motivations that
lead per a person to this conclusion of
claiming to be trans
but the really important Point again
is that
um
you know we often talk about these
people and say Well they're confused
in many cases they're not even really
confused
you know they understand what the
reality is but they have other
motivations
and that's the case for Leah Thomas
pretty clearly
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]